now to Washington where U.S attorney
general Mara Garland is responding to
Donald Trump's attacks on the justice
department and defending special counsel
Jack Smith Smith of course is leading
the investigation that led to 37 felony
counts against the former president over
his handling of documents marked
classified Robert Costa is at the
justice department for us this morning
Bob good morning
Good morning Tony for the justice
department this is yet another standoff
with Trump where its Integrity is being
assailed by one of the most powerful
Republicans in the country and yesterday
its leader pushed back
Mr Smith is a veteran career prosecutor
Attorney General Merrick Garland is
speaking out for the first time since
the indictment of former president Trump
and defending special counsel Jack Smith
as I said when I pointed Mr Smith
I did so because it underscores
the Justice Department's commitment
to both Independence and accountability
his defense comes after Trump has
repeatedly attacked Smith I've named him
deranged Jack Smith on Tuesday Trump
pleaded not guilty to 37 felony counts
for allegedly retaining classified
documents after he left the White House
and failing to turn them over to justice
department investigators on the campaign
Trail a number of Trump's 2024 Rivals
are beginning to express concerns about
the charges I can't defend what is
alleged I know the risk that as I said
even inadvertent release of classified
information about our national security
could present to our Armed Forces but
while former South Carolina Governor
Nikki Haley has criticized Trump's
alleged actions she says she would be
inclined to Pardon him if convicted when
you look at a pardon the issue is less
about guilt and more about what's good
for the country and I think it would be
terrible for the country to have a
former president in prison for years
because of a document's case other two
2024 contenders say hold on it's simply
wrong to be discussing a pardon whenever
we really have not gotten the facts out
despite these legal challenges Trump and
his campaign continue to project
confidence claiming they have raised
more than 7 million dollars since Trump
was indicted still some sources close to
rival Republican campaigns they tell me
they sense Trump is growing increasingly
vulnerable Tony
and speaking of Rivals Bob it looks like
another Republican has joined the race
against Donald Trump to replace uh him
on a republican ticket and it's another
Florida man what can you tell us about
this
another Florida man that's right Miami
mayor Francis Suarez is set to
officially join the Republican
presidential race today making it
official as the first Latino Republican
candidate to join this field Suarez is
one of now three Republicans vying for
the Republican nomination joining Trump
and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis Suarez
does have some support in Miami but this
will be his first test on the national
stage and as part of that he will speak
tonight at the Reagan Presidential
Library Tony
Bob thank you very much